hello everybody III 2015 is well
underway and we just got done watching
Nintendo's digital event that featured
Muppets it was a fun win this year I say
a little bit avant-garde the Muppets I
think we're a good something to do in
their kind of funny they like to do
something different but it didn't really
relate to anything it's not like they
have games that have Muppets in them and
they just had cuts in between where they
were like dancing for no reason
whatsoever yeah it's about setting the
tone or a Nintendo is about fun first
and foremost least that's what they're
trying to communicate and it had a lot
of games to show off today uh
unfortunately a lot of them we've seen
last year including Yoshi's woolly world
Mario maker oh I wouldn't say
unfortunate it's always great to get new
information about some of these exciting
games and I were more years I want big
games Justin yeah it's so that's really
one of the big problems with Nintendo
this year is that it felt like they were
setting us up to have some really big
announcements they had the mother
announcement during the Nintendo World
Championships it's like maybe this is
going to be a mother 3 announcement that
didn't end up happening they cut Zelda
from this year show maybe there's gonna
be a new Mario now though that didn't
happen either and it was a good
presentation it was solid just like
Nintendo noises but I wanted something a
little bit bigger something that had a
really nice punch well obviously the
biggest thing that they had at their
presentation was the new starfox which
is officially titled Star Fox zero and
it is a sort of set in the Star Fox 64
version of that world I'm not really
sure that's very different from the
other ones but it looks very much like
that and what we learned last year and
what we're also seeing in this year is
that the controls are based on the
gamepad right I mean you're using that
to fire through the cockpit using the TV
to screen to steer it looks a little bit
confusing yeah well I think we'll get
some hands-on we'll get to see how that
plays out for me personally is isn't fun
as it is to have those experiences like
Star Fox I was really excited as
embarrassing to admit this but the
amoeba there was so many new amiibo that
they announced and they had once for
Animal Crossing and I was so excited
when they're like oh there's an animal
crossing for wii u there's an Isabella
meebo there's a Tom look amiibo and then
it's like a board game I like oh that's
really not what I want for
animal crossing but there is a new Zelda
at least on the way there is yeah and it
is called the tri Force heroes coming to
3ds it's very similar to the Four Swords
game except this time there are three
there are three because four is too many
apparently and one of the big features
of this game is that you stack
characters on top of each other so that
they can reach you know different
heights to solve puzzles but different
characters can also wear costumes to
give them different abilities if we saw
link dress up as a bomb at one point
also his princess zelda i mean it's it's
a good 3ds game like it looks good but
overall this was a Nintendo that was
treading water more than anything else
it's big Reggie came out of the
beginning he said you know next year
we're gonna have stuff about going on to
mobile we're gonna have stuff about our
index that new platforms those are the
things we want to hear about until then
here are some wii u titles in three 3ds
titles next year is definitely gonna be
really exciting this year was was okay
yeah you know I mean the amoeba news is
interesting because everyone loves
amiibos but isn't that also part of the
problem I mean this would've been the
perfect opportunity for an intended to
say we understand you guys want amiibos
and you can't get them so we're going to
be fulfilling them ourselves or some
sort of system like that it's weird that
they didn't address that issue it was
even weirder that there is a Skylanders
like TYIN and this was also a year the
you know there are so many me bow out
there maybe we're gonna finally get at
Nintendo Skylanders game no no they're
just gonna partner with Skylanders
directly you're gonna be able to use
these amiibo in the game but only two of
those in meebo like really Nintendo is
just leaving money on the table like
Pete I think people would really be into
a dedicated Skylanders like experience
but with Nintendo characters yeah well
there's still a lot of show left to go
nintendo is going to let us get some
hands-on with Star Fox zero so hopefully
Justin I will be able to talk to you
guys about that pretty soon so for all
that more stay tuned to gamespot com /
III for all your III 2015 news